this capsule we will look at what
different types of agents one can
meet in artificial intelligence
so as we live in the ps model
we must also specify what are the
shareholders and sensors it's between
others from the captured observation
by the agent that he will take
decisions to finally make a
action in his environment and
now what we want to see is
how are you that we can distinguish
different ways to model or
to implement the process of
data observation followed by
selection or action decisions we go into
distinguishes four types of agents
people there are actually pulled this
categorization them pulled from the book of
francois dhainaut league
so I'm going to use their nomenclature
we'll talk about the simple agent reflex
then you rumba me is reflected in
of hugo boss jean and jean love you pardon
and finally youtube and ebay egypt
the agent probably the simplest
it is the symbol ief the ex agent
this agent the water all that does is
that he gets via his censors a
observation
it allows him to know what is the state
of the environment or have some
estimates of the state of the environment
and from this estimate of
the state of the environment
well he will invoke knowledge
money that tells him given
certain conditions on the state of
the environment that should be
the action that should be taken
concretely this knowledge there they
take the form of a series of rules
from which to identify for
different conditions what is
the action to be taken by this agent and that's
finally this action that will be
returned and then going to be instantiated
by the shareholders
so in fact in this case we have
really a rather simple agent that acts
only from the perception of
current observation by ignoring
history of observations
previous ones we actually have here an example
or a species of this caliber
of agent where we would have a perception
the interpretation of perception
give an estimate of the state of
the environment
from that state and from
rules that are part of his wish of
prior knowledge of our money
this one will determine what is the rule
appropriate for this state there and then for
this rule is one would determine
is the action to follow
looking for this rule years equal
the dictated action and that action
would be returned by our agent ok so
it's an axis it's actually an agent who
is very very simple and that looks
a lot
an action programming style
we previously saw a capsule
preceding where we have explained
fathers of conditions and action to that
his agent a little more complicated then a
little more powerful is the urban mode
reflex is young so this one from
captured data will finally be able to
update a persistent estimate
of the state of the environment
this estimate loves to be influenced
by knowledge about commenting this
as the world evolves
then also commented what my
actions can influence the state of
the environment
but again from this
estimate the possibly a little more
accurate of my environment
but we will once again invoke
rules of who says given certain
conditions related to my environment
that it should be the action that I
should know and so in this case we have
at least one agent who can accumulate
information in time for better
estimate the state of the environment
it's particularly useful if in fact
I have a
at each is every time I get
an observation only one
partial observation of my
environment
so by accumulating this information there
I can possibly specify that she
is kelly finally the tod of my
environment
so it's going to be particularly useful
in then more powerful in the context
of an environment that is partially
observable what will be much more
interesting though is to add to
our agent a final ability of
make decisions by oneself where one
would no longer have to specify a set of
rules but rather specific a purpose or
start reaching through the agent and in
adding as hostage knowledge to
knowledge about what will be
the impact of an action I'm doing on
the state of the environment
but then it's going to be possible to define
and invoke algorithms
of artificial intelligence that are going
finally be able to forgive who will be able
make the connection between the two in order to
determine from my knowledge
on what is the impact that I can have
on the environment and what is the purpose
that I want to reach what should
to be the next action I have
so in this case we are talking about
really an agent that does not need
specify conditions
actions but who will actually have the
ability to make decisions by
yourself
for example by simulating what she is
what will happen if I do the action
in the current environment that I value
so an example of that would be an agent
who sounds sudoku simulating what is
that could happen if I register as
next digit a given figure that
to give myself in my grid but to be
able to simulate hockey is what
I will eventually succeed in
reach a solution to my sudoku and
in this case also by combining my
knowledge about what my
actions have as impact on
the environment and what is the purpose so
in my example of this caucus would have
solve the sudoku the agent is going to be able
go internal reasoned simulate what
could happen is so
his indications the actions that are going
to eventually reach the
purpose then which ones will not allow
to reach a world where is ultimately
the fourth type of agent this is going to be a
agent utility bad or rather than
specify beginnings at athens
we want to actually specify a function
of utility that for the leg is going to be
in a way a measure of to
how good is he happy if
we want to be in that state
by this measure of telecom tulle is in
able to incorporate preference notions
between the actions among others are going
ability to combine higher utility
to 2 actions that would allow all
two to reach seen but where there would be
an action that might allow for
hold it faster so for example
in the case of a chess player
well there may be two actions that
would eventually win the
part but we will perhaps want
promote actions that will allow
to win faster
ok for maybe diminish people this
that we are wrong and that we lose
long term so that's really the
only distinction between google and
youtube and we are changing the
goal specification by a
specification of a utility that will us
to distinguish quality
finally different actions
the four agents agrees to see in
do are going to use ways
different to make their decision
that's what sets them apart
he uses everything from knowledge to
a priori that it is there then
knowledge that is assumed to be acquired
whether it's a set of rules
applied conditions actions or
knowledge about what is the impact of
actions on the environment then
comment on what the world is changing
world is evolving and yet even a
instill knowledge in an agent
can ask a lot of work
by cons what we could be tempted
to do some agents that could
actually learn this knowledge there
and improved as one's life
of his life people
to improve his knowledge of the world
is what we will see in the short is
also algorithms that are going
allow to do this type
learning the algorithms
learning that will allow a
agent to improve and accumulate
knowledge about his environment and
on his actions